comic book fans the world over are
starting to realize that Black Panther
just might have changed superhero movies
forever from it's jaw-dropping aesthetic
choices the cast's of butt-kicking women
Ryan Coogler Black Panther loses style
and substance and the cinematic
landscape is better for it
think back to phase 1 of the MCU
remember the great jokes
the impressive costume design the
heartfelt expressions of heroism now try
to remember every female character from
those movies as you can
spoiler alerts them mostly the
girlfriends you've got Pepper Potts
Peggy Carter and Jane Foster plus some
side characters like the irrepressible
Darcy SIF Frigga and ultimately the
introduction of Black Widow it's not the
most dire situation in Hollywood but
generally speaking if you're not there
to smooch you're either set dressing or
the one very special lady Avenger who
still spends a chunk of every movie
trying to seduce a prey even phase 2's
introduction of Gamora in guardians of
the galaxy fell into the same pattern as
she's relentlessly pursued by Peter
quill throughout the film and I am NOT
so sorry I wait here to succumb to your
your pelvic sorcery then came black
panther in phase 3 and is cast full of
women
there's Nakia Sheree Okoye and the Dora
mala a queen Ramon de and women filling
out the royal cabinets women are
everywhere in black panther doing
everything both within the MCU and
outside of it's this was pretty
revolutionary while Captain Marvel
starring role in 2019 was in development
for years Black Panthers amazing casts
of women may have gotten audiences ready
to receive the film a year earlier
blockbuster movies don't typically pass
on unfamiliar which makes black panther
feel like kind of americorps it has a
majority black cast takes place in a
fictional African nation inspired by
real African cultures and features
actors speaking cosa an official
language of Zimbabwe and South Africa it
is deeply rooted in specific places
histories and ascetics of most of the
worldwide audience knows little about
and it made over 1 billion dollars
worldwide black panther didn't just
prove that people all over the world can
embrace lives outside their own spheres
of experience
it proves that they can fall in love
with them cheer them on and come back
for more soup arrow movies tend to look
the same save for a signature color or a
formal wear scene it's all based on
ultra-modern tech and military drab
there
can be an interesting look of course but
it does tend to blend together into a
canvas of olive green stainless steel
and dark suits for shut this up
admirably and with the release of the
positively psychedelic thor ragnarok
cemented its branch of the MCU as a
risk-taker
for a while you had three choices you
could be surrounded by shield black or
army base gray or you could be in Asgard
the thing about Tory's aesthetics even
Thor's is that they're familiar we know
how action movies look how high fantasy
looks how military movies look the MCU
did them all well but they've been done
before
then in strides black panther with its
wealth of color texture and fashion both
ancient and contemporary audiences saw
the deep green of the river tribe the
bright coral of the Dora Malaysia and
shuri's up-to-the-minute bomber jackets
costume designer Ruthie Carter who won
an Oscar for her work on black panther
managed to bring color history and an
entirely unique afro futuristic
aesthetic the majority of the audience
was unfamiliar with it's not just
cohesive it's not just new to the genre
it's not just rooted in an absolute
avalanche of research it's all of those
things and more
packed into one movie Marvel's home base
has always been New York City this has
done a lot to bring a unique sense of
place to the stories that take place
within it daredevil she Hulk and
spider-man are live in locations you can
visit that their creators grew up in
that mirror the rapid changes of 20th
and 21st century life with a specificity
that's hard to replicate - metropolis or
Gotham Peter Parker is a boy from Queens
just as daredevil is a child of Hell's
Kitchen the city to use a well-worn but
very true cliche is as much a Marvel
character as Captain America but that
can start to feel a bit confining
especially when the same city is
splashed across the screen over and over
again
Marvel branched out for sure guardians
of the galaxy went far afield indeed but
there wasn't anywhere with the same
strength of location until a condor came
along rooted in painstaking research of
actual African cities and cultures but
cons our looks sounds and feels like a
real place with real history
[Applause]
my prince we are home
audiences agreed cheering when the
heroes return to a condor and infinity
war black panther didn't just show that
audiences can invest in MCU locations
beyond them we see in outer space they
can feel right at home there to the
cella isn't the first royal than the MCU
Thor of course begins his journey as
heir to the throne of Asgard on a path
to discovering what makes someone worthy
of that authority Loki has been twisted
by his desire for kingly power into a
perennial villain both men as one might
expect find themselves often engaging in
battle this isn't the floor these are
after all action movies but the Charla's
kingship is to find as much by his role
in international diplomacy as his
ability to send forces into battle much
of Black Panther is concerned with how
best to share what conscious resources
with the rest of the world how to aid in
global conflicts responsibly and
tellingly how violence is typically led
to tragic outcomes in wakandan history
we don't see T'Challa commanding
conquering armies rather we see him
consulting as advisors speaking at the
United Nations and engaging in
ceremonial combat as means of
transferring power Congo will no longer
watch from the shadows we cannot
we must not the Charla is a diplomat
first and the warrior second a man who
leads his troops into battle reluctantly
superheroes post black panther
unconfined to the Pentagon at military
bases or other martial visions of world
power they debate others open community
centers and strive for global
cooperation check out one of our newest
videos right here plus even more looper
videos about the MCU are coming soon
subscribe to our YouTube channel and at
the Bell so you don't miss a single one
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
you
[Music]